um so before I dive into explaining what
ml base actually is I want to give you a
really brief background like how this
project actually came together because
like it was quite a trip from what I was
doing before I was I'm have a data base
background I've worked mainly on
transaction processing and recently
what's a crowd sourcing and this was a
new thing and of course there is like
the motivation that big data is very hot
and we had like already a couple of
talks about like how big the data no
this is from Facebook and I think
they're like inside the really extreme
example like the LLC the collider which
is really producing a lot of data and so
there's a lot of data around when you
actually need to make sense of a lot of
it and normally if I talk to like
colleagues and so on this is official
explanation and giving them but that's
not the whole reason bias like I started
with my colleagues that worked with this
project called ml base there's a strong
hidden motivation I have and it's
motivated by a PhD comic I saw a couple
of years back and this comic simply
doesn't leave me alone since I joined
Brown as a new faculty member it is
about the hair migration pattern of male
professors and what you see there is
like during like reticule yeah a brief
flirtation with facial hair and like be
it essentially then five years before
tenure it's like slowly migrating from
your top down and you're growing a
beyond you're losing all your head
yeah actually so I did a really really
small study I looked at my colleagues at
Brown like the the colleagues I have in
the database group and that's them so
it's it's a very bad sign already right
so I looked at the other colleague and
that actually just when he started the
tenure-track at Brown and that's one now
so I'm I'm really really worried right
and I thought okay it shouldn't be so
hard actually to verify if this is true
or not if there's a strong correlation
between like how your facial hair over
time essentially migrates if you become
a faculty member compared to the rest of
the population
because there like so many pictures out
there right like Facebook Flickr and so
on it's all accessible the only thing
you need to know it's just like
connected to people look it over time
figure out the main describing features
and so I actually I really wanted to do
that but it turned out to be very very
hot right so and this is a general
problem if you really want to use the
different like algorithms which are out
there in order to make like sense out of
data or big data or pictures or whatever
it is so let's assume even like a
simpler task like let's say we want to
build a simple classifier or some data
set so actually the specification is
very simple I want to classify but then
there's all this crap I have to do and
like I have to know about modern
classification algorithms I need to know
how to balance them I need to implement
some infrastructure in order to try
several of them I need to figure out
what all the right features and so on
there's like this whole machinery
machine learning people actually do over
and over again alright and in the end if
you are not really in this field what
you end up with is like you asked for
head
thank you you actually go to somebody
who actually knows better what's going
on
and this problem that like that there's
so much things you have to do over and
over again that's the motivation behind
ml base so ml base tries to make it a
little bit simpler to use to this all
the inference algorithms and like
analytical elements in general which are
out there so the first goal of ml basis
we need to simplify it the use of
machine learning algorithms and then we
have some other goats to it one of them
we thought we want to make it a little
bit easier to implement distributed
algorithms and a my take on it is really
like from a systems perspective however
if you're switching fields
thing you are doing of courses you get
together with like great people who
actually know this area much better than
I do and in particular I want to mention
like a meet trial worker here on the
left who just happened to be even this
project started in the emblem here at
Berkeley we just got along and we
started to think together and then soon
early after we got like a great PhD
student Evans back here on the right who
is now one of the driving forces behind
this whole project and then many other
people joined and bringing this thing
forward so what is the goal the goal of
ml base is to do something very similar
what databases actually did for data
management it tries to provide a
declarative approach allowing the user
to say what he wants and instead of how
he actually achieves it right so in
databases did that for a long long time
they have a sequel interface which is
the declarative language you specify
your results at essentially and the
system figures out how to evaluate it in
the system figures outward indexes to
use what data structures in between how
to store the intermediate result if it
doesn't fit into memory and so on and we
would like to do something very very
similar for machine learning the user
specifies like in a declarative way at
the moment we call it mq l the machine
learning query language what he wants
and the system somehow magically figures
out how to achieve it in gets the result
back of course this system cannot
achieve the same quality or performance
as a highly-tuned like individual
solution right if you have an expert and
try it like in he knows really the area
perfectly he will always come up with a
better way to solve it to make it faster
and so on but that's also not our goal
and actually it's also not like any
different from a normal database system
a database system gives you a reasonable
performance for most cases but the C++
implementation highly tuned for a
certain application will always beat it
and that's also similar here we just
want to get the same spirit to give the
a pure original implementation which
plus is also like easily
we deployed in a production system I
didn't ormally what like if you look at
the typical workflow people have play
around first bazaar they try to figure
something out and maybe at some points
they come up with something which
actually really works and then they go
to the systems people and just say
please implement that in production
which is just another big burden and
hopefully we can also simplify this
process a little bit so in order to like
drive the development of ML base we have
a bunch of use cases and we developed
this like higher language here are just
some code examples for our first draft
and it's still changing that's
definitely not the final version and it
should just give you like a feel how it
might look like right it's definitely
not to find emerging it the important
thing for example to do a classification
you you load the the features you load
the labels which of the first two
statements then you say you want to
classify and then you say you also give
it a time limit until you when you want
to have like at least one result back
and I come to that in a second why you
need to stop five minute thing so
without going into more detail here how
this language looks like I the important
takeaway is that it we try to provide
something which we call algorithm
independence again you say what you want
and not how to achieve it you don't say
only use this particular algorithm was
this particular configuration setting
right instead you just say you want to
classify and the system should figure
out the rest so you are always asked but
if I know better and sometimes we do you
know better but then we take again a
similar approach with databases also do
the developer can provide hints and
therefore here this whole process in a
certain direction right so that's your
way to influence it but still you can
take advantage of all the built-in
mechanisms in the system so how does
this whole data model work so normally
databases have something like a
relational model behind it which is the
foundation how it works this system is a
little bit different because in the end
what we want to get back as a model and
we designed a new data model which
consists of a stream of
models or tuples which can pass around
so everything is composable but if you
call for example the do classifier which
gives you models back what you're
getting back is actually stream of
different models and you just have to
pick the best one you like right so you
get the like the system is continuously
actually developing or creating new
models are out and you just have to say
no it's good enough now I have enough
quality I'm satisfied I stopped looking
at that so that's the reason why there
is this top statement in there you stop
it means for example after five minutes
just simply takes the best so looking at
the whole infrastructure this is the
initial design of the system it's pretty
much designed along the lines of a
distributed database system but there
are some key differences first of all we
are targeting from the beginning a
distributed runtime but this is like in
the beginning at least it wasn't our
main focus here we just said we may
hopefully we can build on top of other
runtimes like spark even Hadoop but we
want to abstract away from it so that
you can whatever platform you have
in-house you can simply use it and how
we do it we provide something what we
call MLI which is just an abstraction so
that you can use other platforms
underneath and I'll tell you in a second
a bit more about that this next thing is
we wanted this whole system to be very
extendable so machine learning
developers should come along creating
new areas and plug it into the system
and should be taken advantage of like by
the whole infrastructure and optimizer
right so because the field is always
involving people are coming up with new
ideas so we want to leverage them and
this is also a key difference to other
systems right because normally what you
do is you develop an algorithm in our
and if you are really friendly you put
it out on the bed for other people to
use but there's no really common
standard on how to integrate them and
how to treat them off and it always
requires a lot of time to compare them
actually and last but not least we want
to have this like optimize that approach
so that the system really figures out
what's going on and therefore we need
statistics about the data as well as
algorithms and I
to tell you more about that as well as
like an optimization approach to it so
let me start off with the lowest level -
ml eyes abstraction so the ML ilayya is
like a really simple abstraction over
different runtimes it's supposed to
provide both database typical physical
independence meaning that the only on a
high level you specify how something
should operate but then you deploy it
actually on a specific infrastructure so
we have some initial abstractions like
ml table ml metrics and m/l opt and
there are two runtimes right now which
implement them one is back and another
one is to prepare a system we currently
developing at Brown that's all I want to
talk about these abstractions if you
want to know more details and me just
sitting somewhere in the audience over
there so the second component is - of
algorithms and so ml I essentially
provides a very simple abstraction so
that machine learning developers can
implement a distributed new machine
learning algorithm without worrying too
much about the internal power actually X
is executed so the bynars now make it
accessible for the system and the bynars
consists of two parts one is the
implementation which is done hopefully
on top of MLI but you don't have to you
could even use other languages like our
and completely ignore the rest of it but
then the system couldn't also not really
optimize them so it's a trait of you
have to make and in addition what you
need to provide us a contract and the
contract is actually telling the system
but the sector goes and us trying to
tell you the parameter space it should
consider the runtime which you could
derive but at the moment you have to
specify it and some high-level
statistics is essentially an optimizer
can take into account what we have today
is just like what I would call her full
of binders with some really common
algorithms and they are all released as
part of spark so just to give you really
brief feeling how it looks like be
compared for alternatingly square the
implementations for matlab malhotra
flick and
I what you see is ml is actually pretty
close to to MATLAB and performance-wise
there's just like for scaling with
different numbers of machines the total
time it takes you can also see that it's
in the same boat packets for example
graph flap and of course performs better
than my heart which is not really
surprising given how the infrastructure
of X so the total number see are not
really important just like to give you a
feel that we are not much for us if you
follow certain words and how to
implement the algorithm okay so moving
on to the next step the optimization oh
yeah optimization so there are two
things you need to consider there it's
like first of all the statistics about
the data as well as the algorithms and
then there should be some feedback loop
so let me give you a brief idea how that
works so taking a general specification
here on the Left which just says okay
load some data var X is like the
features load some day little data as
labeled in Y and then please generate a
classifier out of it from X&Y in 10
minutes and return back the best model
which is the top so some of these
constructs here can be directly
translated what database people call a
logical plan which is the journal like
specification about the workflow it
doesn't say concretely what algorithm to
use or how to do it it just says you you
have to do a certain operation for
example load the data some of them add
these operations like the load is
directly translated into the logical
plan here yes what we do in addition is
that some other operations like to do
classify for example I expanded to what
we call best practice workflows right
there incorporate like the typical step
developer might take right for example
it searches over different algorithms it
Tunes or like tries out different
normalization factors important in
particular is also like certain validate
steps right like the typical things you
would normally do if you if you try out
a new data set it so we just wanted to
incorporate like as much as possible of
them in in this workflow automatically
for you of course important is in the
moment you get then the final result
back here what you're getting back after
let's say 10 minutes in this case is 1
the summary I want the model like the
best model we found but also the summary
which explains the process versus what
the system was doing to find this model
and what to try it out so in the end
this summary provides your whole lineage
information and it's very important that
you look at this lineage was like what
was actually going on in the background
for you so after we have to logic a plan
now the second step happens which is
actually optimizing this plan what
databases people refer to as a physical
plan we've just then really saying try
the following things out on the physical
happened the following wave is the
following scheduling and the following
techniques and so on so it's like really
taking this like general specification
and translates us to something it
actually can execute and in the
traditional world the optimize are has
actually a very very simple goal it's
time it's the traditional optimizer for
a traditional database system if it
looks at the query it just optimizes
with for time and tries to figure out
the best plan to give to the answer back
in the shortest amount of time in ml
base it's a little bit more complicated
because in the end we have two
optimization goals one is quality and
the other one is actually the time right
so waiting forever for an answer doesn't
help you even it would be the perfect
answer but at the same time if you're
given an answer back really quickly and
in a classification case it just might
be that you say everything falls in
category a which is some very simple
classifier right you could do it
immediately and it also doesn't help you
so you need to trade the both of them
somehow off and the trick what we are
doing is we say one of them who normally
has a budget typically we give it to the
time you say after 10 minutes at least
give us more model back
but in addition but we also assume it's
like even after 10 minutes the system
simply should continue running and
produce further models another
difference is that what we want to do
here is consider the different
algorithms and systems techniques at the
same time so we really want to leverage
both words and there's a lot you can do
and I have some examples later we need
to collect statistics about the data
which databases normally do but also
about the exams size and we want to do
this like all across the steps which
like normally if you have the query
optimizer it's just like it's one query
plan based like here we are more on the
world of like workflows so that also
changes quite a bit like how you have to
do the optimization the last very
important point is this whole thing has
to be robust based like in the normal
traditional database case if you screw
up the optimization face it doesn't
matter so much the only consequences
like your crew is running slower if you
screw it up here and you make the wrong
decisions and your quality might degrade
by quite a bit all right hopefully we
are always better than like normal and
if Britt search techniques but still
it's something you have to consider if
you yeah if you search the space too
aggressively so there are a whole bunch
of possible optimizations out there
ranging from like aesthetic selection
rules because you know that certain
things are better than others rentin
optimizations in the moment you start to
the whole thing you can exploit like
certain caching strategies and use the
the feedback you are getting during
through like running a certain algorithm
and they're like the most interesting
one I think believers just like the cost
based optimizations
I just said like a tortoise cruise rail
you mentioned like really unique
possibilities for example to use
naturalization and indexes to speed up
certain algorithms and that's another
really great opportunity here so let's
let me give you some really like simple
cases just to give you a feeling about
what's not in my room might be able to
do well one thing is it like it's very
simple but often forgotten is just to
check for imbalance of labor's right you
get a you run a classifier you have an
imbalance of labels just saying that
like one of the populations is just all
like over-represented compared to the
other one
it's like to hear the case and the one
down here the red ones are they had and
the blue ones right if you now have a
very simple classify in this case below
here you just say everything should be
classified as red actually your
precision is quite high but it's just an
imbalance of labels because one
population is so over-represented it's
very very simple to fall into this trap
if you don't look into your data more
carefully right so this is something
your system could easily figure out just
based on histograms of the data and
that's something databases already store
today it's not even something you'll be
inventing here we just have to leverage
it in the right way another reason why
to optimize of course quality and we
just ran a really really simple like
experiment here with some publicly
available datasets using SPM and
adaboost ones with like scaled features
that one on the virtual one and what you
see here shows like the green ones are
always the the best the currency rate
and you see there's not a clear winner
here
so algorithms perform differently and
this is really like a naive example here
but the truth just gives you a feeling
that there is optimization potential in
the same regard we ran an experiment for
SVM and adaboost and just varied the
parameter in one case the scale factor
and for other boost regularization a
little bit on the same data set and what
you see here it's like an SVM the like
the performance accuracy of the
algorithm actually heavily depends on
the scale factor so it says like a huge
impact on their courtesy there's like
four other boost the regularization
factor at least for the values which
shows didn't have like a huge impact
pair data set and this is one
that always ran so like the the lines
you see them if they are closer to each
other the impact is not as big at least
for the data this shows do this gives
you already some hint on how an
optimizer might work it for example you
can say okay let's try adaboost first
because it's more robust and then move
on for example to SVM's which more
heavily depends on the different
parameters right and you have to search
longer until you find something good but
that might be then better than the rest
before you go back and tweaking the
parameters here for a boost so another
reason why to optimize is systems
performance so if you run a single
algorithm at a time often you tend to be
i/o bound so there is a very simple
trick in the database community called
shared car sauce which is just saying
okay let's do a couple of things
together right in this case we could run
a couple of like trainings at the same
time and just like do it in Vaughn pesos
I did over the data as long as it fits
into the cache and so on so the question
then comes down to like how many models
at the same time you should actually
train what is the impact for example on
sampling like chemists down samples the
data in order to fit in more models and
want
when does it actually break and in the
same regard like how to leverage the
modern CPUs in particular vectorization
because that influences how much we are
actually an i/o bound so this is again a
very simple experiment we did for one of
the like call loops of one of the
machine learning algorithms and again
it's just like to give you feeling
how does like speed-up might look like
if you do the right thing
so here it's like on the x-axis the
numbers of data elements on the vias
beat up compared to a linear version and
what we are showing here is like
vectorized over linear and what you see
is just like if you are able to squeeze
in more data into your cache lines you
get actually huge speed ups but if you
are too small at some point if the
grades again and that's really funny
effect modern CPUs actually have and so
as long as you somehow you to lie
your cash lines you can get like huge
performance beat ups and I just want to
note here that we are comparing actually
to our self and not Hadoop right so
therefore you don't see like a ten
thousandth of speed-up in in this graph
here like if you if you would compare us
after a dupe the numbers would even look
very better and it's like just a very
low so the direction so currently what
we have we released the MRI interface as
well as a half full of Pinus as part of
spark we have some very simple feature
extractors and some end-to-end use cases
but we are heavily working on in
particular on the optimizer part we are
trying to develop new techniques how we
can leverage like both words the system
works as well at the knowledge how like
machine learning algorithms have to
access the data and how to speed that up
you're looking into the cost of you buy
cost-based optimizer the language
approach as well as like implementing
more advanced machine learning
techniques
so to summarize ima base is the first
declarative machine learning system
which provides your declarative approach
so that you can say what you want and
not how to get it and the system somehow
magically figures it out and its goal is
to simplify machine learning in the same
way as data bases simplified data
management and it's a small teaser
there's like new system couple where we
are working on which again is supposed
to make machine learning implementations
faster and easier to do so with that
thank you and I'm open for questions